[Music]
hey welcome back to the Wolfram tech
conference 2018 I'm Jesse I'm here just
talking to developers and other
interesting people using technology very
cool ways and actually the last talks a
conference I'm sitting here with Chad
and it's gonna tell us a little bit
about what he does at Wolfram and sort
of all right thank you
yeah so I work in the technical services
group that Wolfram research and what
that means is that we take ideas from
customers for projects and we implement
them and that could be at a whole bunch
of different levels so we can take their
existing code that they've written and
they just want to optimize and we can
take that and work on it clean it up for
them make it run faster better more
resilient as needed or we could take
their ideas that they have and implement
them in Wolfram language and deliver a
final product to that and any level in
between services um so what what exactly
you know makes customers sort of
attracted
from my vantage point it seems like most
of the time the customers have some
experience using Mathematica in the past
whether it was in school or they've done
it through their office and they come
across you know some idea that they know
could be done really nicely in
Mathematica or you know any of our
Wolfram products and they're just
looking for help to make that happen to
push them in the right direction or to
just kind of take it over if they don't
have time to do it so do y'all work with
industry is more often or do you span
like yeah we've had projects from a
number of different industries so
education is certainly a big piece of
what we've done but yeah we've worked
with large companies small companies
startups any number of different sounds
company then across a bunch of different
industries from banks to engineering
companies any sort of other types of
companies that you think oh cool so what
are some projects recently that you are
yeah so I'm happy to share some of those
today so yeah I've worked out a couple
but today what I'm gonna be focusing on
primarily is projects that are related
to the general area of three-dimensional
geometry and so yeah the first project
I'll talk about is really just this toy
then I'm holding here and that's on the
table a company called hi cars came to
us and you know suggested oh these
things do come off they they were
looking for ways to help their customers
build structures with this toy so this
is a toy I don't know analogous to Lego
or something like that but it's you know
it's shaped kind of like a tortilla chip
there's actually four different shapes I
know I kind of want to eat one yeah
they're very very pretty very nicely
colored I've only brought a small sample
of them there's all kinds of rare colors
and whatnot but yeah so these these have
these interesting shapes and the
interesting feature about them is that
you can build any sort of feature that
you want if you have enough pieces and
enough imagination to build them
and so what the company was interested
in is creating a instruction set that's
fully three-dimensional so that as one
of their customers is building these
structures they could zoom in on the
object look at it from a different angle
and and be able to really understand
okay where does this new piece come in
and how does it fit and and that's part
of that also we built a tool for them to
build those instructions which also can
be interesting I don't know
GUI of itself where a user and just you
know start with these pieces digitally
and build them up into whatever feature
or structure that they want I have some
example ii yeah sure okay so yeah I mean
maybe I'll back up a little bit and talk
about because there's some technical
details I won't go into too much of
those but so if you can see on the
screen here these are the different
pieces that the company makes so there's
this is the l1 which is the yellow piece
that I was holding in my hand so it's a
four-sided structure there's a couple of
other four-sided structures that are a
little bit more twisted and then there's
this excited structure here and then
there's connectors that hold these
together and the connectors connect on
the middle point of those edges so what
we got from the company are these STL
files that we can import into
Mathematica and convert them into mesh
regions and then as mesh regions we need
to move those in space into the right
locations so the pieces fit in the slots
and so forth of these connectors as you
build them up so yeah those are the
pieces scroll down a little bit here to
show a GUI that this is you know an
early version where I was just trying to
get a sense of okay I have a piece and
I'm gonna add another piece to it how do
I get this geometry correct so I you
know that the original piece we're
looking at is this original kind of
four-sided l1 piece and we can add any
of the other four pieces so I can add a
six-sided piece to that I need to pick
which of those edges that I want to
connect to so any of those I'll just
pick three so that moves the dot
indicates which edge I'm going to
connect to and
we have the connector that most of these
connectors will actually there's two
kinds that one has six slots one has
four slots so this is the actually this
says any of the options here so it's not
actually in these best so I'm not going
to draw it but so let's say I want to do
the four slot and I'm just going to do
that a right angle to this piece and I
click on the button and this hopefully
will show where that new piece looks on
here and this is you know so for my
adult Minh purposes I wanted to keep
track of how these pieces are moved so
that's this is Wolfram language
expression transformation function which
says how that new purple piece was moved
from its original location in STL file
to where it belongs
yeah yeah and this this case this
project was really interesting to me
because this gets a lot more complicated
as you add more and more pieces and then
for instructions what the company was
interested in is you know if we're
building something like an airplane for
example there are different sub
assemblies of that airplane so that you
know the first set of instructions maybe
is related to building the fuselage of
the plane then you have a next set where
you're building the wing and at the end
of each of those steps then you need to
join those bigger pieces together and so
yeah keeping track of this geometrically
and computationally in Wolfram language
took a little bit effort to do by this
the tools that we have here are very
powerful and help us to to manage that
really well
yeah and so I'll just scroll down here
and I mean we did build a full GUI for
that I just kind of show a screenshot
here of some of the features that we
have so you can add a different color
you can continue adding you know that
previous one I was showing out I didn't
actually render the connector in the
full application we do render the
connectors and just to show that you
know one of the interesting things that
you can build here is this guy right
here so here is so this is one of the
many final structures yeah correct so
this is an example from the company so
this is a turtle and if I can rotate it
you can see the the green sort of
flappers the brown shell and the green
head there and the fun thing is the the
PCs the connector piece is kind of look
like eyes in this case the turtle
character yeah and again you can build
that if you go to high Parsons webpage
you can see a number of different
examples of things you can build with
this okay so we did a project for a
company called ata and in their case so
they have an experimental physical
system that they want to basically
visualize with Wolfram language so we
built again a GUI for them based on our
CDF technology and so yeah so CDF is a
computational document format and so
analogous to a PDF which you use with
Adobe Acrobat for example to read those
but it's our technology and it allows
you to share
wolfram documents with anybody in the
world and all they have to do is either
open it up in the Wolfram cloud or get
the CDF player which is a free
application open it on their software
and then they can interact with the code
that you put together for them so it's
like the underlying technology right
right yeah and so yeah in this case the
and I'll show you here so this is not
their actual application but I'm just
going to show you you know an example of
the types of things that we could do for
them so in this case we you know I've
imported from the web this I think was
an STL file again of a dog just as an
example and yeah right and so what the
first thing that they wanted to do was
you know they place some sensors over
the object so we needed to create an
interface where if you click on this
object it would place that sensor where
the mouse was clicked and so there's a
little bit of computation involved in
that base some of it is provided with by
Wolfram language itself so when you're
looking at a three-dimensional graphic
like this when you click there's an
event handler that tells you you know
basically the intercepts of that box
three-dimensional box so you does so now
you have a line and the computational
part of it is we have a line that we
need to intersect with some of these
polygons that are in the mesh so that's
part of the code that we put together to
solve that's pretty cool that you can
[Music]
sort of just like that's like function
and sort of like its handling it like
dynamically as you click it correct yeah
yeah so the app that takes user inputs
and yeah and does the calculations on
the backend all the calculations which
is quite extensive you don't see it all
but just and and this this is not a
simulation right this actual
three-dimensional space that we're
placing these sensors and so there is
some pretty significant geometric
geometrical calculations that are
happening okay so and this is the GUI we
put together so it's a real again just
one piece of the goo that we built for
them so we wanted to place sensors on
this three dimensional object so this
responds to a mouse click so if I click
anywhere on this dog and if we want to
put a sensor say it's somewhere near his
eye we could do that then we could
rotate it into any of you that we want
and let's say we want to put a sensor on
its stomach which is pretty flat I guess
but there's another sensor right there
we could put a sensor on his toe and so
forth as many as as we would want to to
mimic the actual experimenting okay just
for a visualization purposes I'll put
this there again this this is just kind
of one step at a time that I'm showing
in this notebook we can we've actually
have assembled this all into a single a
single file that has all the
interactivity built together but yeah so
that's the first step and then the next
step is in their case their reading data
from sensors and then they want to
visualize that and so this is what the
next demo is doing and so this is
bringing in dogs so we can look at it a
couple different perspectives so look at
you know beside views and you can see
where the sensors replaced remember I
put a one in stomach and on the foot
somewhere near the eye and we can again
rotate this one to look at you know
whatever view that we want these ones
are fixed and this is some of the
the function L is kind of hidden behind
this GUI here but we have a button here
that would connect to the sensors the
actual physical sensors that they have
then we could start an experiment where
we in this case I'm simulating it so the
data is actually generated by
Mathematica itself well in their case
they have an actual product that they
are working with but hopefully it's not
gonna disappear buddy disappeared on us
I was still spinning that's good I have
too much you never know but yes so in
this case yeah so in the actual
experiment what's happening is that give
it one more chance
there's a lot going on in some of these
sensors so yeah we could just sit on
this for now I guess yeah so and then
what happens is that right you know
before we start the experiment these the
sensors that we place our black
indicating that expert has started once
we start collecting data then these are
colorized based on some color scale that
the user gets to select and you can see
that just visually what the different
values are coming from sensors so this
is not necessarily about this book but
maybe like what's you know what's kind
of your favorite sort of project I
imagine you worked I've worked on it
like
yeah that's a good question I just in
general I I get really excited when my
customers are excited about their
product and what about what I'm building
I'm happy to work on any number of
different things but for me the biggest
thing is the the people that I'm
building for really care I'm not just
building it for the sake of building it
so they're gonna share these guys are
going to share with their customers
other projects they're going to share
with our customers sometimes you use
internally but yeah that's that's
something that's fun I also personally
really like taking on new challenges so
before I had started this I had some
knowledge of three-dimensional geometry
but I've learned a lot through this
process and you very much enjoyed that
and enjoyed getting to know the
different tools that are in Wolfram
language but yeah if you ask me anything
in the world I wanted to do that's a
real question but yeah I mean I'm happy
to continue working on geometry but I
have other projects for universities
working on course management systems
that's also pretty exciting and
challenging where the students really
care that this thing works great so I
think thank you that it works so what's
the most challenging aspect of being a
part of the firm Technical Services
yeah so I think it's really related to
the thing I like the most about it which
is that we have customers in many many
different fields and they come in with
an idea and sometimes I'm not an expert
in it maybe someone else on my team is
depending on you know how our work
situation your project situation is you
know and expertise you know projects
your shifted to to whoever is best
suited to it but yeah the challenge is
that people come up with these really
challenging ideas and challenging
concepts and and some of these you know
we're pushing you know some of the
limits of what we've seen done with
Wolfram language in Mathematica and we
push those limits and sometimes it works
out really well sometimes it doesn't but
now that then we know and branched out
in the space that probably no one's
explored before and so that it's fun but
it's also a little scary sometimes we
don't know it's going to work sort of
like very like also maybe sometimes
vague like you know things they want to
do and it's like not only do you have to
you know code it and put it together but
you also have to make sense of it too
right right and and that's a big
challenge to we we on our team are
generally technical minded we've mostly
been trained as engineers some
physicists and so we think a certain way
but sometimes customers come in who
don't have that technical expertise but
they have a vision of something that
they want to be built and so having that
dialogue and working through okay here's
you know here's what's feasible here's
what's hard here's what I don't know if
we can do is part of that just ongoing
dialogue that we have with customers so
try to walk them through the step from
initial ideas to final completion
well thanks for taking the time to stop
me do you have anything else you want to
tell maybe like the viewers about tech
services or any of the projects or the
language well yeah I mean we are always
happy to have new projects and if you
have an idea for us please contact us
we're definitely open to ideas and if we
can take it on we'd be happy to do so
awesome thank you thank you
[Music]